Oh, I imagine a dystopia.
A dystopia where big rivers flow from the inland ice.
Where the icebergs calve ice by the millions, by the tons, into the water.
Where the entire ice landscape has turned completely dark because of the melt away.
Where immense parts of the landscape is now soil and little trees start to grow.
I imagine Northern Canada and the Northern Siberia where the permafrost melts
and the cities will fall into ruins because they were founded on a bog.
Where tons of methane rises into the air which and increases the feedback processes
creating hellish machines of climate change which
again contributes to thawing even more permafrost and more methane will mix into the air.
This is the future – It is not particularly pleasant.